odette est en vacances en vivre il
décide de prolonger son séjour pour
visiter montréal en lumière mais elle
veut en avertir sa famille qui habitent
à l'extérieur de montréal dans la cabine
de bell elle utilise sa carte de crédit
elle fait cinq appels d'une durée
moyenne de 2 à 3 minutes chacun
cette active elle pu s'amuser mais quant
aux d'être soi sont relevés de cartes
crédit elle y achever la compagnie win
acteurs qui gère les appels interurbains
de belles payer par carte de crédit lui
a facturé plus de 40 de dollars pour ses
50 ans comment est ce possible
le tarif des appels interurbains fait à
partir de cabine téléphonique et plus
réglementé compagnies peuvent donc exigé
tarifs qu'elles veulent en fait
odette aurait dû prendre le temps
d'écouter ou complet le message
d'accueil du wimax terre on lui aurait
alors expliqué les frais d'interurbain
élevés auxquels elles s'exposent les
wings tel a accepté de réduire la
facture de dette
comme quoi ça vaut le coup d'honneur
téléphonie